jesse smallett is guilty that's what a
jury decided on thursday agreeing that
the former empire star is guilty on five
of the six counts of disorderly conduct
for which he was charged jesse faces up
to three years in prison here's a little
rewind of events back in january 2019
josie reported to chicago police that
these two brothers abel and ola osindayo
allegedly attacked him in an act of hate
the actor who is black and gay claimed
the men yelled racist and homophobic
slurs poured chemicals on him and put a
noose around his neck jesse broke his
silence about the alleged incident on
good morning america and there is no
doubt in your mind
what motivated this attack i could only
go off of their words i will never be
the man that this did not happen to
i am forever changed
and i don't subscribe to the idea that
everything happens for a reason but i do
subscribe to the idea that we have the
right and responsibility to make
something meaningful out of the things
that happened to us good and bad but
jesse quickly went from an alleged
victim to a suspect in 2020 the singer
was charged with six counts of
disorderly conduct for allegedly lying
to police about the attack the
prosecutors claimed that jesse paid abel
and ola to help stage the entire thing
i've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one fast
forward to his trial this week and jesse
continued denying his involvement saying
quote there was no hoax you ready to
tell your truth i'm ready to do what i
got to do
and the two brothers shared their
version of events claiming it was jesse
who was the mastermind behind the entire
ordeal and paid them 3 500 to carry it
out but jesse claims the money was for
workout and nutrition advice in court
abel testified that jesse wanted him to
fake beat him up and agreed to do it
because he felt like he was indebted to
him because he helped further his acting
career also a major part of the
prosecution's case video footage like
surveillance cam of the brothers buying
supplies for the attack which they say
jesse gave them and this police body
camera footage from the night of the
attack that's jesse with the rope around
his neck so what's next for jesse
following his guilty verdict sentencing
for the actor will take place in the
coming months stick with e.t as this
story continues